Michigan is the latest state to enact a
law making cyberbullying a crime the new
law defines cyberbullying as posting a
message in a public forum that would
make a person fearful of bodily harm or
death if found a cause of victims death
cyberbullying in Michigan is punishable
by up to 10 years in prison and a
$10,000 fine Michigan College student
hailey petrowski's experienced with
cyber bullying in high school inspired
the state's new law people began making
fake profiles saying awful things about
me threatening to do things to me if I
didn't do bad things to myself and it
really became too much to handle on my
own so on January 18th of 2014 I
attempted to take my own life and
thankfully there was someone in my world
that reached out to me and told me how
much I mattered in the future the law is
the ultimate I'm here for you but it
also reaffirms to people who are
experiencing cyber bullying and bullying
that this is happening and people are
going to do something about it and it's
not just words
they're Trotsky says a suicide
prevention group called Project
semi-colon helped her through the tough
times CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Kleeman is here with what you can do to
protect yourself and your children good
morning Ricky good morning so first lady
Melania Trump has made this you know a
key platform as first lady no federal
laws out there though how important and
how structured are the state's laws what
you have is no federal law it's been
debated for years it had to do with the
conflict with the First Amendment
because of course we deal with the issue
of speech in cyberbullying but the
states all states have some kind of law
they vary from civil enforcement a lot
of laws are about policy with his
schools so the schools have to adhere to
certain strictures in order to keep
bullying or try to keep bullying out of
the school but now we have found from
state-to-state Michigan's join the ranks
of criminalizing cyberbullying behavior
and I say bravo to Melania Trump for
having her be best campaign but public
awareness is not enough the only thing
that's going to work here I say is Swift
and certain punishment how hard is a
tricky to prove cyberbullying leads to a
suicide very very difficult indeed and I
think that that is the problem not only
for Michigan with this new law but for
any state and any prosecutor that is
trying to say a suicide was caused by
cyberbullying because we often have all
kinds of other circumstances yes you can
have mental illness you could have
parents getting a divorce you could have
someone who simply breaks up with that
person the the male or female who has
left that person you could have drug
problems there are all kinds of issues
that get in the way of causation so with
the lack of a legal remedy what should
parents do if their children are bullied
well the the ultimate responsibility is
always going to start with the parents
the first thing they have to do is keep
an open and safe environment with their
own child so that the child feels able
to say I'm being cyber bullied without
fear that his or her cell phone is not
good what does a parent should I
confront the other parent I think that
it is very important for parents to
become proactive safe space for the
child
second confront the other parent in an
adult way not in a blaming way but be
able to have a conversation third line
go to the teachers and the principals go
to the school enroll the school as your
partner and if all else fails call the
police one of the problems here though
is a lot of times parents aren't aware
their kids are being cyber bully because
it happens right yeah but create the
same space they don't talk to you yeah
right Ricky thank you thank you
appreciate it
the national suicide prevention hotline
is open 24 hours a day for anyone who
might need help that number is